In this problem, a warehouse measures
250 ft by 800 ft with a storage height
of 24 ft.
Due to the aisle requirements, 18% of
the storage volume cannot be used for
inventory.
An automated storage system is proposed
that reduces aisle space to nearly zero.
The automated system costs $650,000
while the conventional shelving system
costs $275,000.
If the warehouse earns $18 per cubic
yard of additional storage capacity,
what is the net financial benefit of
installing the automated system?
So, this problem is a cost-benefit
engineering economics problem and is
really easy to solve. So, let's get into
it.
First, let's just get the warehouse
volume
in cubic feet.
So, that's going to be 250 ft
times
800 ft
times 24 ft.
And this will give us
4,000,000
800,000
cubic feet.
Next,
let's convert that to
cubic yards since this is what the
problem is going to ask for later.
So, 4,000,000
800,000
cubic
times
1 cubic yard
over
3 feet cubed per cubic yard.
That's basically 1 over 27 if you want
to do a shortcut.
And this will give us 177,000
cubic yards.
Next, let's multiply by
the 18% of storage volume that we could
be getting back
if we use
an automated storage system.
So, that's going to be 177,777
cubic yards
times
0.18
which will give us
32,000
cubic yards.
Now, we can find the value of those
at $18 per cubic yard.
So, 32,000
cubic yards
times
$18
per cubic yard
equals
$576,000.
thousand dollars.
So, now all we have to do is subtract
the difference of the two system costs
and compare it to the value
of the space that we have recovered
using the automated system.
So, that will be 576
thousand dollars
minus
the difference
of 650
minus
thousand dollars
or the difference of
375.
And that will give us
thousand dollars
which is closest to our first answer
over here.
So, this is a really quick and easy
problem to solve as long as you're
paying attention to your units and
recognizing that you need to account for
the difference in costs of the two
proposed systems.
So, again we'll just compute the total
volume, convert to cubic yards, multiply
by the lost volume percentage,
multiply by the value per cubic yard,
and then subtract the additional cost of
the automated system.
And that's it.